the 45th annual Kennedy Center Honors
brought politicians entertainers
together last night in Washington D.C
now it was mostly a musical group of
honorees featuring singer Gladys Knight
Gladys Knight look at Gladys she looked
looking good in the band you two always
looking cool and Oscar winner speaking
of cool George Clooney and his gorgeous
wife Amal Clooney there too ladutiere
has a look at the celebration
art has the power to bring us together
the Kennedy Center went all out in a
show filled with love and humor for the
entertainers honored this year once
heard Gladys sing the ABC's and I
thought I was in church true story
the ceremony featured tributes to the
Empress of Seoul Gladys Knight whose
Pips joined Garth Brooks on stage
believer
oh man
[Music]
contemporary Christian artists and
chart-topping pop star Amy Grant was
also honored she has never lost sight of
the things that really matter Faith and
family I'm here for Gladys Knight can't
you tell
adorned in a dress filled with pictures
of a frequent co-star Julia Roberts he
plenty of humor and praise at close
friend and actor George Clooney he is
profoundly present and attentive to the
world around him somehow Tanya makes the
piano come alive sounding sometimes like
wind chimes
Tanya Leon has composed groundbreaking
orchestral ballet Opera and coral Works
rounding out the class you too who stay
in power across 40 years was honored
with touching tributes there's the songs
that speak to the most personal and
private places in our hearts an
electrifying performances
[Music]
elevation
all right all right also attending last
night Paul Pelosi husband of house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi who made his first
public appearance since he was attacked
at their home in October you can watch
the 45th annual Kennedy Center Honors
December 28th at 8 pm 7 Central right
here on CBS The Pips Garth Brooks yes
you too Irish immigrants America
Eddie better that's the fun about that
that award show not only are the
awardees so great the people they bring
out to celebrate and that's half the fun
to see who's going to be coming out
that's right so you get a little tease
there but then it's going to be on CBS
later and how they mix the genres yes
don't we love Julia's dress with George
that's so cool